Paris London New York Milan Zara
Ismailis at home in all the major
fashion hubs
she's been an internationally successful
model for thirteen years originally from
Afghanistan she was first discovered as
a teenager in Germany while out shopping
today she's 30 she says she'll never
forget her first photo shoot shooting I
did it secretly because I knew my
parents wouldn't approve but I was
curious to know what it it'd be like do
you know idea think about clothes she
was just 14 and hadn't been in Germany
for long her family believed modeling
was out of the question for a Muslim
woman
taking photos in general is not so
common in Afghanistan but it's
especially problematic for women if you
take a photo privately and don't show it
around that's different
but generally modeling as a job doesn't
exist they want women to stay in the
background so it's not desired
this is often so personal it's good when
she initially as Miley wanted to be an
aviation electronics engineer after high
school but her curiosity got the better
of her at age 17 she broke with her
family's strict Muslim traditions going
on to become the first top international
model born in Afghanistan the smack
money issue a nun Allah she can tell
that her past her shaped who she is
she's different and special customers
that come to the showroom noticed that
too and asked her about it making music
to zubatov
and
ESMA le is keen for others to benefit
from her experiences as a refugee she's
an ambassador for the German
government's & hué discrimination agency
and works for an association that helps
people in Afghanistan Zaria smiley was
born and raised in Kabul
in 1998 she fled to Germany with her
family to escape the terror of the
Taliban their journey took months and
included times of extreme hunger
violence and terrible fear can't invited
um Volga hide standing here in the
forest we had to walk forever
we went many kilometers on foot in the
dark at night here's another scenic
rubbished road or here I think this is
where we were left in a car alone in
Slovakia eyelining Lhasa warden using
photos to reconstruct her journey from
Afghanistan ESMA Ellie's been able to
address some of her traumatic
experiences also the subject of a book
she published last year but she still
loves her former homeland as Mihaly
recently designed her own fashion
collection inspired by Afghan dress she
completed it in just two weeks light and
Schaffhausen David when you're
passionate about something you somehow
get a special strength it was the same
when we were on the run I wonder now how
I got through the Hunger these days if I
don't eat for half a day it's unbearable
I can remember we were at the border for
three days with nothing to eat or drink
we ate snow to survive I transformed
that into an inner strength this solace
covered another stack
even though she's well used to coasting
down the runway when it comes to
presenting her own collection of designs
she suddenly feels very nervous if a
Prosecco ordinary glass I've left some
of the things in traditional form from
Afghanistan so that people can see the
difference this waistcoat is an original
from Afghanistan but some of the women's
dresses I've converted to a European
style the event is packed with
high-profile guests Zara ESMA Ali is not
only unveiling her first collection
she's also seeking to raise funds for
her new charity project called culture
coaches
the project appoints visitors to help
refugees settle into German society and
its ways while at the same time
introducing Germans to the culture of
the refugees home countries szura's goal
of raising 40000 euros is reached before
the event is even over once more
Zhora Ismaili has taken a big risk and
again it's paid off